nous sommes dans le 15e arrondissement
de paris sous vichy et travail une
importante communauté libanaise
la double explosion de beyrouth a fait
au moins 171 morts et plus de 6000
blessés
trois cent mille personnes sont devenues
sans abri alors pour leur venir en aide
on s'active ici pour récolter notamment
du matériel de première nécessité
c'est tellement des vêtements on a reçu
beaucoup de vêtements pour nouveau-nés
les bébés tout le monde de tout âge au
la logistique à des vêtements dès 10
heures on nous a aussi donné la hausse
ce matin des maillots de sport qui sont
tout neufs c'était super farrar ami
shana ils sont une dizaine de bénévoles
franco-libanais engagé ici dans cette
salle de la mairie du 15e arrondissement
de paris depuis le début de la semaine
ils participent à une grande collecte en
faveur du liban ils ont laissé leur
colère leur tristesse de côté pour
soutenir la population libanaise
j'essaie d'aller voir mes amis d'aller
voir des gens des français pas de roms
ou des libanais aussi pour leurs invités
à vraiment nous aider ans en ce moment
là pour reconstruire déjà là beyrouth
les routes qui a été détruite
maintes et maintes fois à peu près je
vois je vois cette fois et quand je dis
détruite c'est vraiment totalement
détruite et mais avec avec les jeunes
avec la volonté du peuple
on va la reconstruire coûte que coûte
malgré la difficulté de l'épreuve ces
bénévoles se disent touchés par cet élan
de solidarité beaucoup de donateurs se
sont en effet mobilisés sans distinction
de couleur d'origine ou de religion pour
la thune pour un billet d'avion j'irais
volontiers aider les gens
maintenant on essaie de faire ce qu'on
peut avec le regard qu'on a ici aussi
c'est à dire en donnant des vêtements
etc
maintenant comment être solidaire je
sais pas en fait c'est peut-être pas
maintenant mais c'est plus les mois qui
vont venir qui vont être durs peut-être
pour les personnes aussi face à des
trucs pareils à plus de nationalité
c'est juste humain humains et relation
ce qui compte c'est dur d'être loin et
de vouloir aider de ne pas savoir quoi
faire donc là quand on se retrouve et on
voit des gens qui donnent même s'il
donne peu s'ils donnent trop c'est ça
fait toujours très plaisir sans nous et
peuvent plus faire quoi que ce soit nous
sommes là pour les supporter
malheureusement parce qu'on n'a pas un
gouvernement qui les supportons nous la
diaspora libanaise
on doit les aider quelques pas au delà
des produits de première nécessité le
liban a aussi besoin d'argent de
beaucoup d'argent
les dégâts matériels sont estimés à
beyrouth à 3 milliards de dollars
nadia chahed êtes une femme d'affaires
libanaise installée en france depuis 31
ans
suite à cette catastrophe elle a créé
une plateforme au double objectif
recueillir des messages de soutien et
d'aidé à la création de cagnotte
c'est pour avant tout se mettre au
courant exprimer ce pouvoir
échanger travailler à distance quelque
part et il y a eu beaucoup qui ont
proposé leurs maisons qui ont proposé
des faits qui ont proposé leur la france
compte 36 mille lits bellay sur son
territoire la plupart d'entre eux
regardent avec émoi ce qui se passe de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée dans
l'espoir d'un meilleur avenir pour ce
pays de 4 millions d'habitants
déjà durement touchés par les crises
migratoires économiques politiques et
sanitaires